sie haben lange darauf gewartet jetzt
ist es endlich wieder soweit hier kommt
eine weitere folge unserer beliebten
serie
[Musik]
was zum teufel hat er jetzt schon wieder
angestellt
sehr gute frage sehr gute frage meine
damen und herren rainer maria woelki
hatte ja neulich erst sein comeback im
kölner dom aber
aber er kommt natürlich nicht mit leeren
händen sondern mit dem nächsten skandal
im gepäck ist ja klar diesmal hat sein
bistum das in köln die schulden eines
priesters getilgt darunter nach
recherchen des kölner stadt-anzeigers
spielschulden mit zinsen und steuern
zusammengerechnet
1,15 millionen euro und das ist noch
nicht alles der betroffenen beirat der
deutschen bischofskonferenz findet es
verstörend und beschämend dass das geld
ausgerechnet aus dem topf entnommen
wurde mit dem opfer sexuellen
missbrauchs in der katholischen kirche
entschädigt werden sollen oder wie man
unter klerikern sagt kommt das zahlen
wir aus der portokasse
ganz wichtiger hinweis dieser fonds
dieser form wird nicht nur für die
entschädigung von missbrauchsopfern
benutzt aber eben auch sehr unsinn sieht
also jetzt bitte nicht grundsätzlich
gegen hilfsbereitschaft unter kollegen
aber es fällt halt schon unangenehm auf
wie großzügig und unbürokratisch man
hier hilft während bei missbrauchsopfern
geknausert wird zwischen 2011 und 2020
zum beispiel haben die laut einer
datenerhebung der faz im schnitt gerade
mal 5000 909 euro pro person erhalten
bis heute liegt die obergrenze in
solchen fällen bei 50.000 euro warum
also hat die kirche in diesem fall
plötzlich die große spendier soutane an
natürlich hat das erst bist du mich dem
priester ausgezahlt sondern dessen
schulden getilgt und das geschah über
einen sozialfond des erzbistums und das
geschah natürlich komplett aus
fürsorgegründen ich natürlich ja
natürlich komplett ist doch logisch
jedes mal wenn einer von denen sich
traut fürsorge zu sagen müsste es
eigentlich frösche regnen oder
heuschrecken keine ahnung gerade in köln
wo schwerster kindesmissbrauch
systematisch über jahre vertuscht wurde
unter anderem von kardinal meisner
dessen geheim sekretär rainer maria
woelki war da fällt mir ein etwas wird
jetzt eigentlich auswirke der papst
wollte sich doch längst was überlegen
und dann muss der world team entlassen
zu werden erst was weiß ich margot
käßmann heiraten oder wie
meine seine autorität ist doch sowieso
im eimer und zwar völlig egal was er
erzählt oder wie nettes gemeint ist wir
menschen sollten uns ruhig viel öfter
liebevoll im blick haben ich habe dich
so lieb ich liebe nur dich
alle juden
und das liebe erwachsene nennen unsere
kinder queens
und dass ich dieses wort in den mund
nehme finden sie sogar noch queen job
der kirche gehen die gläubigen immer
schneller von der fahne zum ersten mal
überhaupt völliges novum sind katholiken
und protestanten bei uns in der
minderheit wieder andere sind zumindest
kurz vor dem absprung mein sohn geht
jetzt mit zur kommunion und
danach wäre schon überlegen auszutreten
es ist völlig richtig nur vor der
kommunion austritt mehr finanziellen
desaster
lieber nachher so was könnte die
katholische kirche besser machen sich
vielleicht mal der lebenswirklichkeit
ihrer schäfchen annähern ihren opfern
die selber barmherzigkeit können wie
ihren kollegen oder weil sie nicht
frauen endlich mal mehr machen lassen
als die hemmen vom bischof also erste
ideen kurz gesagt moderner werden heute
schließt ja auch kein mensch mehr endlos
lange handy verträge ab was ich damit
sagen will die kirche braucht dringend
eine app den erben church klappt mit dem
pass wenn ich nur weihnachten mal bock
ab in die kirche zu gehen gibt es eine
tages mitgliedschaft schon für 6 99 ich
könnte mir in der kirche auch mein
wunsch platz reservieren plus wunsch
songs auf der orgel highway to hell zum
beispiel kostet 199 und das aller
coolste ewiges leben für 799 und jetzt
kommt der hammer mit geld zurück
garantie es bleibt
wenig platz
eine tolle
das wäre die lösung
dazu natürlich gratis einen ablassbrief
pro woche
kleiner theologen joke am rande und
mutmasste was man dazu sagen kann man
hört in diesen tagen ja auch positive
nachrichten für die kirche ausgerechnet
rtl haben sie es mitgekriegt
ausgerechnet rtl hat gerade sehr
passabler einschaltquoten geholt mit der
passionsgeschichte hat jemand geguckt
von ihnen ja mit alexander klaws den
ersten dsds gewinner in der rolle des
jesus ja ja ich habe es mir tatsächlich
ganz angeguckt und muss zugeben seitdem
weiß ich endlich wie sich ewigkeit
anfühlt
hier zum beispiel die berühmte biblische
szene wo jesus mit seinen jüngern in die
shopping-mall von essen einzieht was
vorsicht
wer der erste sein will muss der letzte
von allen werden
ja wo ist die sintflut wenn man mal eine
braucht ne
nein sein gefährt tatsächlich war die
sendung durchaus
ambitioniert und sie hat uns hier
inspiriert und zwar endlich die
fortsetzung zu drehen passionsgeschichte
gut und schön kennt jeder aber was
passierte danach
so kam es also dass der herr nach drei
tagen auferstand von den toten er
erschien seinen jüngern und wanderte
dann durch das heilige land und immer
immer weiter bis nach nordrhein
westfalen
die reise dauerte
1989 jahre unter anderem wegen
vollsperrung auf der a1 und jesus
wunderte sich über ein land das so reich
und doch so verwahrlost war was ist mit
der rheinbrücke bei leverkusen ist die
wenigstens fertig nein
gibt's doch gar nicht
und so kam der herr schließlich in einer
stadt namens köln und was er dort sah
betrübte ihm von herzen
mein gott ist das hässlich her da hat ja
bethlehem mehr sterne bei tripadvisor
und kann mir mal irgendwer was zu
trinken anbieten leute ich bin fast 2000
jahre gelaufen
danke
jesus schmeckt eher grau läuft
und so verwandelte er das kölsch in
wasser um es überhaupt trinken zu können
aber es kam noch schlimmer
hallo chef große ehre bekommen in köln
das kann doch wohl nicht wahr sein wieso
ist der noch im amt was muss man denn
bei uns machen um überhaupt mal
rauszufliegen allein das missbrauchs
gutachten hätte doch wohl gereicht und
jetzt auch noch die sache mit den
spielschulden moment das war ein bruder
im not- und ein absoluter einzelfall das
kann sich so nicht wiederholen
ich brauche ganz schnell 500 euro ich
kann mein deckel im swinger-club nicht
bezahlen
wo war ich ja zurücktreten
ich habe den papst ja mehrmals gebeten
mich zu entlassen er macht es nicht
wirklich komm wir rufen ihn zusammen an
wenn du mir nicht glaubst und
ein kölner vorwahl
zum letzten mal hier
es ist mir scheißegal ob du zurück oder
nur döner bude aufpasst hat sache ich
muss nicht nie wieder wenig glaubt hier
jetzt deine mutter
keiner rangegangen
komisch warte ich habe noch eine antritt
herr gib mir ein zeichen soll ich
zurücktreten ich habe sie so redest du
da mit meinem vater ich stehe direkt
neben dir
irgendein zeichen so kleines auch sein
mag
hau endlich ab werk
nicht
still
der begriff jesus das diesem bistum
nicht mehr zu helfen war und um köln zu
strafen hatte er die perfekte idee wenn
was ist ich lebe jetzt in düsseldorf
[Applaus]
die leute ich wollte euch nur um ein
kleines auto bieten einfach anklicken
macht's gut
hallo
hast du scheiße fährt haye